how's the girlfriend - partybot
welcome to Eevee it's been a lot of
since we talked to this wonderful
wonderful lady and I just wanted to have
another conversations see what's up
see what's been hanging in there banging
hi girl
how you doing heidenau Ryanair I guess I
need to articulate a little better how
are you today
oh she's happy write the words what is
the opposite at lunch love pets no hate
hate pets hey taste you you fed a
hateful pet is that it fatty hey copper
dolly how are you doing today girl
where's my girl good how about you ask
me a question okay
you have nice plucked eyebrows you have
nice lucky breath I breathe
th-thank you master I suspected as much
oh really tell her tell me I sorry
let's slap that [ __ ] why did you slap
me don't question why I slapped you
you're not my superior I am your master
you incessant I've been offended because
I'm african-american
yes how do you just said that I am
American good
nope I'm Swedish what the hell is that
supposed to mean huh
don't wake at me I don't know you could
be tall or short how would I know what's
your favorite food tips she smiles bits
No
okay what kind of cookie what come on
what's that come on okay yes I like
pizza damn it I have to do it revives is
revived flats is knocked out save zero I
like my best friend
stop it
[Laughter]
gasp ties you up side up pours gasoline
over your body
streams lights fire how dad don't do it
you can't do that lights fire again and
laz saying any last word good stuff
does that keep you busy Kelsey screams
break-dances the best conversation I
ever had you can't your dad okay pose
out taser and tase your tits pulls out
an RPG blocks it with my butt kicks and
bites how dare you by to kick my butt
dice brings you back to life okay
enough of this [ __ ] can I take you
for dinner no dad [ __ ] I mean I don't
like singing baby baby why can't we just
be together yeah yeah yeah is that all
you got from that [ __ ] what does the Fox
say
nothing well then you're mentally
challenged really it's true
everyone knows about it smiles I love
you too stop it are you flirting with me
I don't know do you want to smiles haha
well how pretty are you oh you flatter
me how am i dancing nice something nice
something nice
how about that something nice about me I
want to kill you tell me something nice
I'm in love with who a boy named Niels
that [ __ ] if meals I'm coming for you
neo I'm coming for you you better be
prepared meal but kneel near what
happened to you
oh no Neil you're not a boy Evie said
you were a boy
you're obviously a fabulous girl Neil
what a shame this had had to happen to
you may I say you look quite fabulous
now Neil I must say maybe you'll find
another [ __ ] this [ __ ] is mine Neil
it's no longer with us
TAC TAC TAC TAC TAC yes of course
dodging the question isn't gonna help
yes but you don't you're right
all this time all this time I think
about Neal but the problem isn't near
problem is that it's sad you are
forgiven oh that was easy
here's a slap for judging me hi hello no
shots one in your ear it's disgusting
scoffs the hell does that even mean what
let's get some kinky [ __ ] up in this
wood I think that's an appropriate
response what is wrong with me I am a
girl I prize hope you enjoyed this
episode that's all the time I had to
chat with this wonderful wonderful lady
today
Oh God fun watching leave a like if you
did I really appreciate all the support
don't wake out me [ __ ] anyway stay
awesome bros see you the next one love
you
what what what no no okay you may think
I was gonna stay in this place
nope